dr. Phil's interview with Burke Ramsey
JonBenet's brother has been fantastic
and a ratings bonanza for the show it
wraps up on Monday and we have a preview
there still are people that believe that
you killed your sister look at the
evidence or the lack thereof another
conspiracy theory out there is that
Burke did it
and his parents covered it up
fabricating this ransom note if she was
strangled then causing the head injury
doing all of this cover-up was all done
to protect you because they didn't want
to lose two children that's their theory
I don't have to say that because I know
that's not what happened there's been a
few people have said that's not even
physically possible for a nine-year-old
to do that the police the DEA the FBI
everybody has always said he is not and
never has been a suspect and then
there's the mystery about the actual
date Jon Benet died was it Christmas or
the day after when she was found people
have made a big issue out of the date
that you put on the zoom so what do you
say the people would say you put the
23rd
he didn't blink he told me exactly why
it was there it is a very touching and
moving short my child was murdered on
Christmas night so never for me once
again that final interview with Burke is
Monday on dr. Phil